dayz is whether it's an Oklahoma hi
Daisy welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
hey thanks so much for taking my call
sure I'll tomorrow well I'm just a
little context out 24:08 forty five
thousand a year no kids
student loans are paid off and I have
about twenty six thousand and dead and I
guess I was mostly just calling for some
reassurance and guidance a lot of heavy
steps wanted to but I got divorced
earlier this year and I just had a major
impact on the timeline of my financial
problems so it's just really
discouraging even though I'm following
your steps well just to look at how much
further you know and I don't know normal
goals like getting out of debt and
buying a house are now you're twenty
four how long were you married and two
years we got married in college he was a
medical student not student and I went
into journalism so really until recently
I've had the security of my salary being
a drop in the bucket and you know very
soon and in the divorce I lost my
savings entertained some credit card
debt we had pain plan to pay off
together and so since then of course on
how did the doctor not get the credit
card debt and he got the savings and the
journalism student got the credit card
debt and not the savings um fast divorce
with no lawyer that's how it happened
fast divorce what with no lawyers oh you
got you got you got home there's what
you're saying yeah yeah pretty much you
just want it out there that bad huh um
yeah I think a little bit of the both of
us kind of rushing it okay so you ended
up with credit card debt that is $26,000
oh I'm sorry and the credit card debt is
about seven thousand the rest of the car
loan oh I'm sorry
okay you have an eye
$18,000 car all right yes okay okay
and you're 24 and you said you make
26,000 what do you make put it 45,000
45,000 okay all right what do you do for
a living I'm a reporter at a local
newspaper okay good for you
all right well you know your your reset
is is you know it's coupled with a heart
break is part of the problem what you
thought the 30 year old you was going to
look like is not gonna be and you have
to you know you're grieving that
heartbreak because it hurts and then
there's the actual financial mathematics
to the pain that says I got this credit
card debt I got this car and now I gotta
try to you know make it on $45,000 a
year which you can do I mean you're
single lady making forty five in
Oklahoma you can make it you know like
you're going to starve or something it's
just you're not going to accelerate
super fast unless your career does or
your income does and so if I'm in your
shoes I'm probably getting out of this
car yeah because I think that car is a
big chunk of your world
and do you know what it's worth um it's
pretty new it's it's a 20-19 so very new
okay so is it worth about nine I mean
you owe $19,000 on what's it worth it's
um it should be worth about that you
know it's a very recent purchase oh okay
it was I was a bad purchase because
you're it's it's half your annual income
you're it's going to take you a long
time to pay that off
and it's gonna stunt your growth
financially and so you should be in
about an $8,000 car ten thousand dollar
car that you pay off very very very
quickly with your seven thousand dollars
in credit card debt because if you don't
have a car payment you have E credit
cards all sudden your budget opens up
yeah and that that's where you're headed
so
yeah I think that was a probably an
emotional purchase you needed a car for
some reason after the divorce and you
wanted the security of a brand-new car
or the prestige or something to feel
good I don't know whatever but you you
stepped in it for sure and that's what I
would do if I were in your shoes yeah in
yeah I know you're going through a lot
of pain I know you're hurting but you
called and said I need a reset I need to
think about how I'm gonna win in my
future again because the way I was gonna
win is not here anymore we're doing it I
have to do it differently now and the
fastest way I know to build wealth for
anyone is to not have debt and you just
took on a big chunk of debt on something
that's going down in value very rapidly
the good news is it's new enough you can
probably get out of it if you wait a
year you're gonna be upside down in it
by five grand and you're gonna owe
$5,000 or more on that it's worth so I
wouldn't wait around I want to help you
turn this around Daisy hold on I'm gonna
have Kelley pick up and we're gonna get
you signed up for Financial Peace
University
it's our nine week class and it includes
a one-year membership that gives you
access to a ton of other stuff use all
of these tools it's about a thousand
dollars where the stuff I'm giving you
use all these tools to reset your life
and I can be honored to be part of your
healing that way and I'll give it to you
as my gift to help you turn this around
sorry you're facing all of this